back now at 7 30 here on CBS mornings
and as electric vehicle sales take off
the White House is hoping that the
batteries that power them will be made
right here in America problem is that is
not the case right now generally
speaking 75 percent a battery
manufacturing done in China to change
that the bite Administration is awarding
2.8 billion dollars in Grants to a dozen
states all in an effort to boost battery
production but all of those EV batteries
require critical minerals minerals like
nickel senior National and environmental
correspondent Ben Tracy is going to take
us now to a Minnesota town that could
play a very big role in our electric
future and he finds out why some
residents there are worried
in Tamarack Minnesota
withering winds have made it hard to age
gracefully you're likely to see more hay
bales here than actual people and the
town's Heyday seems to have played out
long ago
trains that Rumble through town could be
stopping to pick up loads of much-needed
metal thanks to a massive deposit of
nickel discovered underneath this
unassuming home how big of a deal is a
nickel deposit like this this is a
world-class deposit Todd Malin works for
Talon Metals his company hopes to turn
100 acres of Farmland into the nation's
largest source of nickel a mineral
critical for electric car batteries
nickel makes the batteries last longer
so the cars go farther and it's expected
the world will need 20 times more of it
by 2040. currently the U.S produces less
than one percent of world Supply leaving
American EV makers reliant on supplies
from places like Russia China Indonesia
and Australia no country wants to be
dependent on another country for a
source of its energy President Biden has
put nickel on a list of minerals
essential to National Security and wants
more of it mined domestically so this is
your newest drill yes I can drill about
8 000 feet about a mile and a half
underground
Talon has drilled nearly 500 test holes
mapping them in 3D and sorting the core
samples inside this Warehouse in
Tamarack this is about nine percent
nickel head geologist Brian goldner says
the nickel they found here is some of
the best in the world so when you guys
drill down there I got a sample and you
saw that what were you thinking we
thought it was fake at first Talon hopes
to open the Minnesota mine in 2026 when
the only other U.S nickel mine is set to
close it says it will create 300 jobs in
the poorest county in the state the
company already has a deal to supply
nickel to Tesla now it's up to the state
of Minnesota to approve the mine and
some people who live here have questions
where is the scientific data that says
this is safe Melanie Benjamin is chief
executive of the Mille Lacs band of
Ojibwe its tribal land is less than two
miles from the proposed mine she worries
about pollution impacting fragile
Wetlands where native tribes fish hunt
and have harvested wild rice on the
water for Generations
there is a spiritual connection to the
water to the plants to the animals to
the land it's going to devastate the
land and the land may never come back
from that Devastation that's pretty
scary a group of homeowners worried
about sulfuric acid runoff from the mine
leaking into pristine waterways have
banded together to fight the project
Talon says it will process the nickel
out of state and says the deep
underground mine poses little risk to
the environment
do you believe any of that asking Talent
or asking any Mining Company about how
they're going to take care of the
community and the environment is kind of
like asking the fox how he's taking care
of the chicken coop and do you
understand why people around here would
be worried given the history of the
mining industry which is not
particularly great absolutely we totally
understand the context and the history
we understand how precious this
environment is the need for mining like
this raises An Inconvenient Truth there
is a dirty side to clean energy so if
you think about solar power wind power
batteries all of those are dependent on
metallic minerals instead of saying yes
or no about mining operations we should
be transitioning to conversation about
how and where but if the where is where
you live that conversation is not so
simple when this mining is done they're
going to pack up and leave and we're
going to be the ones left here for CBS
mornings I'm I'm Ben Tracy in Tamarack
Minnesota